la fuerza del agua haciendo estragos en
los últimos días decenas de personas se
han sumado a las labores de recuperación
de comercios hogares e instituciones que
fueron afectadas por las lluvias que
azotaron el estado brasileño de minas
gerais
es difícil porque estamos tratando de
recuperar no sé hace dos años y ahora
esto vuelve a pasar no sé si podré
soportar otro en igual
todo el mundo tiene miedo
en apenas una hora sube y no da tiempo
de sacar casi nada
las lluvias vienen afectando a brasil
desde finales del mes de noviembre del
año 2021 y se han intensificado en las
últimas dos semanas el estado de bahía
al noreste del país ha sufrido los
embates de las precipitaciones dejando
al menos a 100.000 personas evacuadas y
24 muertos en minas gerais las lluvias
han provocado el desbordamiento del río
para opera y han vuelto a afectar a una
comunidad indígena que hace casi 3 años
sufrió las consecuencias de las rupturas
de la represa de brumadinho que mató a
más de 250 personas sentimientos muchos
trillones ahora son partidos es un
sentimiento muy triste de desamor ver
esta comunidad en ese estado por mí
nunca regresaría a que mi corazón está
roto el corazón está sangrando mientras
las lluvias generan caos en el este y
noreste del país en el sur los
agricultores de soya sufren por una
sequía prolongada que podría acabar con
el 90 por ciento de las cosechas en
algunos campos según reuters que cita a
productores a menos que cambie la
situación en las próximas semanas